Alright, hey, check, check. Hello. This is Eddie Vedder. The guys do not know that I'm doing this. They don't know I'm here early. I'm usually late. But, you know, they want to start this thing early and then where the fuck are they? Come on, fellas. Let's do this. Welcome to Smart Life. This is what I want to bring up. When we had dinner on Sunday, we started talking about words that we get mixed up. Like, I was, I never knew the difference between rife or ripe. Like, if something is rife or rife with, with, with information or ripe, you know, what, what is the, and then Jason, didn't you have one? Yeah, my, my big question up until a couple of weeks ago, a couple of years ago, rather,
好的，嘿，试音，试音。你好。我是埃迪·维德。伙计们不知道我在做这个。他们不知道我来早了。我通常都很晚。但是，你知道，他们想早点开始，结果他们到底死哪儿去了？来吧，伙计们。我们开始吧。欢迎来到《SmartLife》。这就是我想提的。周日我们吃晚饭时，开始聊起那些我们容易搞混的词。比如，我以前从来不知道 rife 和 ripe 的区别。比如，如果某事是 rife（充斥着）还是 ripe（成熟的），你知道，到底是什么，然后杰森，你不是有一个吗？是的，我，我直到几周前，或者说几年前，最大的疑问，
was making ends meet. Now, I always thought that people would say that as a, well, we're just trying to make ends meet, meaning we're just trying to buy the cheapest kind of meat. You know, we're not, cause we're poor. We're trying to make ends meet the meat at the end of the cow. Oh my God. I need a new crew. I need a new fucking crew. I got that till a couple of years ago, but it's really about completing the circle, make ends meet, M-E-E-T. Now, if I'd been a reader, I would have seen this in print and known that it wasn't M-E-A-T. Yeah. Now, the more egregious one, Sean, before we move on here, Will.
是“make ends meet”（维持生计）。现在，我一直以为人们说这个词的意思是，嗯，我们只是在努力买最便宜的肉。你知道，我们不是，因为我们很穷。我们是在努力凑齐牛屁股上的肉。天哪。我需要一个新的团队。我需要一个该死的新团队。直到几年前我都是这么理解的，但它实际上是指完成一个循环，make ends meet，M-E-E-T。现在，如果我是一个爱读书的人，我会在书面上看到它，并知道它不是 M-E-A-T。是的。现在，更离谱的一个，肖恩，在我们继续之前，威尔。
Fuck it. I can't wait. This is, all of this is so, I'm so close. This is, Mr. Guest, we're getting right to you. Stay awake. So, but this is music related, so you'll enjoy this. Mr. Guest is from the musical. You know what he's going to say, Sean. So, Sean, Sean P. Hayes. Yeah, that's me. A music fan and also a music student, aren't we all? Student. Studied music. This is, this is... When we were watching the Beatles documentary together. Oh, that's right. Yeah.
去他的。我等不及了。这，这一切都太，我太接近了。这是，嘉宾先生，我们马上就到你那儿了。保持清醒。所以，但这与音乐有关，所以你会喜欢的。嘉宾先生来自音乐界。你知道他要说什么，肖恩。所以，肖恩，肖恩·P·海耶斯。是的，那是我。一个音乐迷，也是一个音乐学生，我们不都是吗？学生。学过音乐。这是，这是……当我们一起看披头士纪录片的时候。哦，对了。是的。
We all watched the Beatles documentary. Jason Dingdong didn't understand that the Beatles, he spelled B-E-A-T. Right. Like the beat, like one makes a beat. Wait, and you knew this? Jason, you knew this? Yeah, man. I did not know that. Isn't that so stupid? The bug, the Beatles, is B-E-E-T.
我们都看了披头士的纪录片。杰森·丁东没明白披头士（Beatles），他拼成 B-E-A-T。对吧。就像节拍（beat），就像一个人制造节拍。等等，你知道这个？杰森，你知道这个？是的，伙计。我不知道。这不是很蠢吗？甲虫，披头士（Beatles），是 B-E-E-T。
Right, but I never knew it was a pun on beat, like a rock beat, like a drum beat. So you did know that the Beatles, the bug, is spelled with two E's? I do. I just didn't put two and two together. You didn't put it together. Well, listen, I can't be the only person out there. Well, no, most of those people are locked up. You know what? You know what? We're going to get, we're going to get online. We're going to get people responding to this, like on our social saying, like, I was today
对，但我从来不知道这是 beat 的双关语，就像摇滚节拍，就像鼓点。所以你确实知道甲虫（Beatles）是用两个 E 拼写的？我知道。我只是没把这两件事联系起来。你没把它们联系起来。好吧，听着，我不可能是唯一一个这样的人。好吧，不，那些人大多都被关起来了。你知道吗？你知道吗？我们要上线了。我们要让人们回应这个，比如在我们的社交媒体上说，比如，我今天
years old, which by the way, that expression, fuck off. But wait, don't you think, don't you think, if you would, if you want to make it right, a comment on any one of our feeds or whatever, and admit that you didn't understand that the Beatles was a pun on the word beat and not the bug. Yes. Please join me. It'll really help Sean out. It will help Sean out.
才岁数，顺便说一句，那个表达，去死吧。但等等，你不觉得，你不觉得，如果你愿意，如果你想纠正它，在我们的任何动态上评论，承认你没明白披头士是 beat 这个词的双关语，而不是甲虫。是的。请加入我。这真的会帮肖恩一把。这会帮肖恩一把。
It'll really help me out. Listen, it's good. We've got Bennett and Rob. I want everybody to, we've got Bennett and Rob and Michael here. Can they contribute as well? Just to say, what did you guys know? We've never done this before, but you guys knew about the pun. I knew about it for sure. I knew about it.
这真的会帮我一把。听着，很好。我们有贝内特和罗伯。我想让每个人都，我们这里有贝内特、罗伯和迈克尔。他们也能贡献一下吗？只是想说，你们知道什么？我们以前从没做过这个，但你们知道这个双关语吗？我肯定知道。我知道。
I knew about the pun. You did for real? Michael Grant Terry knew about the pun. Yeah. And Rob. Are you serious? You guys, you're not, well, I admit it. I'm going to look dumb.
我知道这个双关语。你真的知道？迈克尔·格兰特·特里知道这个双关语。是的。还有罗伯。你是认真的吗？你们，你们不是，好吧，我承认。我会看起来很蠢。
Hang on. Hang on. We haven't heard from Robert Armier. Armier. Rob. How about someone else? Beatless. Beatless.
等等。等等。我们还没听到罗伯特·阿米尔的声音。阿米尔。罗伯。其他人呢？Beatless（无节拍）。
Beatless. It's like smartless. Beatless did not clear. Smartles. They went with beatless. Beatless. So they, oh my God. They, we, wait, I was about to accuse them of ripping us off, but I guess that was 60,
Beatless。就像 Smartless。Beatless 没有通过。Smartles。他们用了 Beatless。Beatless。所以他们，天哪。他们，我们，等等，我正要指责他们抄袭我们，但我猜那是 60，
70 years ago. So it's a problem. It's a nommage. Oh, it's a nommage. That's what it is. Thank you. Thank you very much. So yeah.
70 年前的事了。所以这是一个问题。这是一个致敬（hommage）。哦，这是一个致敬。就是这样。谢谢。非常感谢。所以是的。
So we cleared that up. So that's, so the Beatles. Super inspiring though. Yeah. They're really good doc. Right? Watching their. I mean, let me just say, I wasn't the only person in the room when we were all watching
所以我们澄清了。所以那是，所以披头士。不过超级鼓舞人心。是的。他们真的很棒的纪录片。对吧？看着他们的。我是说，让我说，当我们一起看的时候，房间里不止我一个人
that together that didn't know that the Beatles was a pun on the word. Somebody else who's in, who's a big listener of the show. She also didn't know. She was our kind host too. She was our kind host. And let's just say, we're not going to, no, you know why we're not going to out her? Because she's a friend. She's a friend.
不知道披头士是那个词的双关语。还有一位也是节目的忠实听众。她也不知道。她也是我们亲切的主持人。她也是我们亲切的主持人。而且我们说吧，我们不会，不，你知道为什么我们不会曝光她吗？因为她是朋友。她是朋友。
Okay. And we're going to give you, we give you initials at least, right? No, no, no. We don't need to. We just, just say that she's a friend. She's a friend. She's a friend. She's with the capital F.
好的。而且我们会给你，我们至少给你首字母，对吧？不，不，不。我们不需要。我们只是，只是说她是朋友。她是朋友。她是朋友。她是那个大写 F 的朋友。
She's a friend with the capital F. That's right. It's 8 p.m. Massey TV. Well, now we know. Oh, shoot. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
她是那个大写 F 的朋友。没错。现在是晚上 8 点，Massey TV。好吧，现在我们知道了。哦，糟了。对不起。对不起。
Oh, Sean, we've said too much. On 2B. On 2B. Do I have 2B? Listener, sorry for that. Okay. Mystery guest. Sorry for that.
哦，肖恩，我们说得太多了。在 2B 上。在 2B 上。我有 2B 吗？听众，抱歉。好的。神秘嘉宾。抱歉。
Here comes. Here comes. All right. After this, after, after going on like this, there are going to be more like a misery guest. Am I right? Do you like the rock and roll? I love the rock and roll.
来了。来了。好吧。在这样之后，在，在这样继续之后，会有更多像苦难嘉宾（misery guest）一样的人。我说得对吗？你喜欢摇滚乐吗？我爱摇滚乐。
The actual instruments being played, plugged in, played loud. This isn't dance music listener. This is heart pounding, head banging, mosh pitting, stage diving, rock and roll. But his music is also melodic at times. It's rhythmic. It's complex. It's emotional. The lyrics are often poetic and complex.
真正的乐器被演奏，插上电源，大声演奏。这不是舞曲，听众们。这是心跳加速、疯狂甩头、人群冲撞、舞台跳水，摇滚乐。但他的音乐有时也很悦耳。它有节奏感。它很复杂。它很感性。歌词通常富有诗意且复杂。
In February, he will release his first solo album in more than a decade called Earthling. We know mostly from the group, Pearl Jam. He's one of our most enduring rock stars of voice for a couple of generations now. One of my all time favorites, folks, Mr. Eddie Vedder. No way. What? Hello there. It's so crazy to meet you.
二月，他将发行十多年来的首张个人专辑《Earthling》。我们主要从珍珠果酱乐队（Pearl Jam）认识他。他是我们最持久的摇滚明星之一，是几代人的声音。我一直以来的最爱之一，各位，埃迪·维德先生。不会吧。什么？你好。见到你真是太疯狂了。
This is so cool. Eddie Vedder, I mean. Hey, Will. Now, Eddie, I have it. By the way, how are you? So nice to meet you. You too, Sean. Eddie, we met once years ago at SNL.
这太酷了。埃迪·维德，我是说。嘿，威尔。现在，埃迪，我有它。顺便问一下，你好吗？很高兴见到你。你也是，肖恩。埃迪，我们多年前在《周六夜现场》（SNL）见过一次。
Do you remember that? I do remember. Wait, wait, wait. Tell us about that. Why would you remember that? What happened? He took a photo of us together, right, Ed? It was the after, at the after thing.
你记得吗？我记得。等等，等等，等等。告诉我们关于那个的事。你为什么会记得那个？发生了什么？他给我们拍了一张合影，对吧，埃德？是在那个派对之后。
Yeah. And it was that memorable. Just one photo with Will Arnett. It'll do it. It'll burn it into your brain. It was. No, I wish it would have went longer, but those things are sometimes crowded. But that was the highlight of the night.
是的。而且令人难忘。就一张和威尔·阿奈特的照片。这就够了。它会刻在你的脑海里。确实。不，我希望它能持续更久，但那些场合有时很拥挤。但那是那天晚上的亮点。
We had a little corner. Well, now you get 60 minutes with this guy. Can I do a little thing about you, Eddie? So when I was in college, I was on the entertainment committee and we were in charge of getting bands to come and at Illinois State University, the greatest university in the country, you played. And I don't know if it was the same ticket as the Red Hot Chili Peppers or not. I think it was, right?
我们有一个小角落。好吧，现在你有 60 分钟和这家伙在一起了。我能为你做点小事吗，埃迪？所以当我在大学时，我在娱乐委员会，我们负责邀请乐队来，在伊利诺伊州立大学，全国最伟大的大学，你表演过。我不知道那是不是和呛辣红椒乐队（Red Hot Chili Peppers）同一场演出。我想是吧，对吗？
Yeah. And maybe you opened for them or was it just a double? Yeah, it was also the pumpkins and the peppers, I believe. And the pumpkins, right. Wow, you remember. And I remember seeing you. I was like, everybody in the audience was just blown away and you hadn't really become you yet and the band was just kind of on the rise, right?
是的。也许你是他们的开场嘉宾，还是双重演出？是的，我相信还有南瓜乐队（Smashing Pumpkins）和辣椒乐队。还有南瓜乐队，对。哇，你还记得。我记得看到你。我当时想，观众中的每个人都被震撼了，你当时还没有真正成为现在的你，乐队也正处于上升期，对吧？
Do you remember when you weren't you? Yeah. What was that like, Eddie? Better. Wait, Sean, you organized a night that had Red Hot Chili Peppers, Pearl Jim and Smashing Pumpkins. Well, we, as a committee, discussed of the band's touring, who we would go after, who we thought the student body would like to hear.
你还记得你还不是你的时候吗？是的。那是什么感觉，埃迪？维德。等等，肖恩，你组织了一个有呛辣红椒、珍珠果酱和碎南瓜乐队的夜晚？嗯，我们，作为一个委员会，讨论了乐队的巡演，我们想邀请谁，我们认为学生群体会喜欢听谁的。
And this was at your college. God, what a school. And yeah, it was wild to see you then and how have you been? Do you remember that night, Eddie? What was the venue like? Was it kind of a hall? It was called the Bone Center. We used to call it the boner.
而这就在你的大学。天哪，多棒的学校。是的，那时看到你真是太疯狂了，你最近怎么样？你还记得那个晚上吗，埃迪？场地是什么样的？是一个大厅吗？它叫 Bone Center。我们过去常叫它“硬邦邦中心”（the boner）。
How'd you guys come up with that? Was there a lot of lovemaking happening at the center? No. Boy, if Will Arnett was there, I bet Eddie would remember. No. Eddie, so Eddie, before you were Eddie, were there any, were you always doing music and wanting to, planning on dreaming of being a rock star? Were there like some regular jobs that kind of put some food in your mouth before you
你们是怎么想出那个名字的？中心里有很多亲热行为吗？没有。天哪，如果威尔·阿奈特在那里，我敢打赌埃迪会记得。没有。埃迪，所以埃迪，在你成为埃迪之前，有没有，你是否一直都在做音乐，并想要，计划着梦想成为摇滚明星？有没有什么普通的工作在你
started successfully rocking and rolling? Oh, for sure. Yeah. I ended up doing a lot of midnight shift work, which came in handy because that's kind of the job now is that you kind of... Night work. You're not supposed to peak to like nine or 10 at night and that kind of... That lifestyle ended up working for the current occupation.
开始成功摇滚之前让你填饱肚子？哦，当然。是的。我最终做了很多夜班工作，这派上了用场，因为现在的工作就是这样，你有点……夜间工作。你不应该在晚上九点或十点之前达到巅峰，那种……那种生活方式最终对现在的职业起作用了。
But yeah, I know a lot of waiting tables, a lot of... I really had like a passion and an instinct and a drive and all these things to... If I was going to try to write songs, I was at least going to just give it my best shot and worked hard in little bands and then would do midnight shifts and do all the making of flyers and I heard when you talked to Dave Grohl the other day and he was talking about recording with cassette to cassette players and going back and forth, I mean it's the same thing that I did and I think that comes from a desire, that's not... That was before the advent of home multi-track recording, which was in the early mid-80s,
但是是的，我知道很多端盘子的工作，很多……我真的有一种热情、直觉和动力，所有这些东西……如果我要尝试写歌，我至少会尽我所能，在小乐队里努力工作，然后做夜班，做所有的传单制作。我听说你前几天和戴夫·格罗尔（Dave Grohl）谈话时，他谈到了用卡带录音机录音，来回切换，我是说这和我做的一样，我认为这来自于一种渴望，那不是……那是在家庭多轨录音出现之前，那是在 80 年代初中期，
which we finally got around to, I'm sure Dave did too, but before that it was really just wanting to be able to write a song yourself or have it sound like a drum machine or have it sound like a real piece of music even though you're doing it by yourself and I think that came from listening to early Pete Towns and demos which back then were on bootleg finals that I would acquire and hearing that one guy could kind of play everything. What about how Dave played every single instrument on that first album for Foo Fighters? That was pretty impressive, wasn't it? Yeah, he gave me that tape long before it was out.
我们最终接触到了，我相信戴夫也是，但在那之前，真的只是想能够自己写一首歌，或者让它听起来像鼓机，或者让它听起来像一首真正的音乐，即使你是独自完成的，我认为这来自于听早期的皮特·汤申德（Pete Townshend）的小样，当时是在我买到的盗版黑胶唱片上，听到一个人可以演奏所有东西。关于戴夫在 Foo Fighters 的第一张专辑中演奏了每一种乐器，你怎么看？那令人印象深刻，不是吗？是的，他在发行前很久就给了我那盘磁带。
I think it just said this side. Play here. Did you give him any notes on it or was it pretty much done? Oh, it was done. It was done. And then their first tour, it was actually Dave and Mike Watt. We were supporting Mike Watt who had just put out a great record with a lot of collaborations and so when we took it on the road, it would be me, Dave and Watt at the end of the night
我想上面只写了这一面。在这里播放。你给他提过什么建议吗，还是它基本完成了？哦，它完成了。它完成了。然后他们的第一次巡演，实际上是戴夫和迈克·瓦特（Mike Watt）。我们支持迈克·瓦特，他刚刚发行了一张很棒的唱片，有很多合作，所以当我们带它上路时，晚上结束时会是我、戴夫和瓦特
as a three-piece and then Pat Smear would join us, etc. Oh, cool. And then I would start the night playing drums with a little three-piece and then Foo Fighters would play and it was like their very first tour. I want to say it was something a little insane, like 28 shows in 30 days. Wow. You know, I wanted to ask you, Eddie, about like you were saying, Jason touched on, then you touched on when Dave was talking about recording and trying to do like a real patchwork
作为一个三人组，然后帕特·斯米尔（Pat Smear）会加入我们，等等。哦，酷。然后我会开始晚上打鼓，用一个小三人组，然后 Foo Fighters 会演奏，那就像他们的第一次巡演。我想说那有点疯狂，比如 30 天内 28 场演出。哇。你知道，我想问你，埃迪，关于你说的，杰森提到的，然后你提到的，当戴夫谈论录音并尝试用卡带和东西做真正的拼凑
sort of multi-track with cassette tapes and stuff and like using the home stereo, his folks' home stereo and stuff, which is so cool and just that desire to like get it out because he knew obviously he had like a song or an idea of something that he had to do it. So he had to and you probably heard us rambling on before you came on here about watching the Beatles dock together and I was, Sean will attest to this, Jason was minding his own business but I was obsessed with watching this documentary, watching that process, that creative process. It's one of the, I said to them the other night, it's one of the most inspiring things I've seen in years and years, watching that process and watching Paul work out songs and John
那种多轨录音，比如使用家庭音响，他父母的家庭音响之类的，这太酷了，只是那种想要把它表达出来的渴望，因为他显然知道他有一首歌或一个想法，他必须这样做。所以他必须这样做，你可能听到了我们在你来之前关于一起看披头士纪录片的闲聊，我，肖恩可以证明这一点，杰森在忙自己的事，但我沉迷于看这部纪录片，看着那个过程，那个创作过程。这是，我那天晚上对他们说，这是我多年来看到的最鼓舞人心的事情之一，看着那个过程，看着保罗创作歌曲，约翰
and watching him go through, let it be and trying to figure it out and then Ringo sitting next to him, blah, blah, blah. What I'm getting to is- Promise? Promise. Yeah, I don't want this to turn into one of those like, Eddie Vedder says on the podcast that he puts him, you know, he's like the Beatles or like one, you know, because that's what people like to do.
看着他经历《Let It Be》，试图弄清楚它，然后林戈坐在他旁边，等等等等。我要说的是——保证？保证。是的，我不希望这变成那种，埃迪·维德在播客上说他把自己，你知道，他就像披头士或者像一个，你知道，因为那是人们喜欢做的事情。
They want no one's listening. But what is, did you have that experience as a kid as well where you were just like, had all these ideas for songs that you just knew had to come out or like you had a vision for it? Like was that kind of coming out of you in that way, in the way that I imagined it would? We know one thing I have to say about the documentary which was enlightening and exciting for me to finally realize that I had something in common with John Lennon and that is that I'm always the last guy to show up at practice.
他们想要没人听。但什么是，你小时候也有过那种经历吗，你只是，有所有这些歌曲的想法，你只是知道它们必须出来，或者你对它有一个愿景？就像那种方式从你身上出来，以我想象的那样？我们知道关于纪录片我必须说的一件事，这对我来说是启发性的和令人兴奋的，终于意识到我和约翰·列侬有共同点，那就是我总是最后一个出现在排练现场的人。
How about that? He was so late all the time. In common. However, I was early today. I'll be late for practice, but see, I, you know, maybe I'm a little too comfortable with the fellas in the band, but you guys, I deeply respect, you know. You were very on time. No, I'm usually late.
怎么样？他总是那么晚。共同点。然而，我今天很早。我会排练迟到，但看，我，你知道，也许我和乐队里的伙计们太熟了，但你们，我深深尊重，你知道。你非常准时。不，我通常很晚。
The guys would know this. I'm usually late because I'm working on a last minute lyric or something. We have some, I can make some progress from my side of the fence. But I think early on, I think it was just, you know, how to cross that bridge or how to build the bridge from playing somebody else's song to writing one yourself. And, you know, like our lead guitar player, Mike McCready, is just, you know, unbelievable. And I was never going to be able to do that or my interest lied into kind of communicating and getting lyrics and chords and momentum and beat, you know, rhythms and to communicate.
伙计们会知道这一点。我通常很晚，因为我在处理最后一分钟的歌词之类的。我们有一些，我可以从我这边取得一些进展。但我认为在早期，我认为这只是，你知道，如何跨越那座桥，或者如何建立从演奏别人的歌到自己写一首歌的桥梁。而且，你知道，像我们的主音吉他手迈克·麦克雷迪（Mike McCready），简直是，你知道，令人难以置信。我永远无法做到那样，或者我的兴趣在于沟通，获取歌词、和弦、动力和节拍，你知道，节奏，以及沟通。
And that started early on, you know, and it still continues. It's still the ever moving goal line, you know, that you try to get across on a daily basis. Was it more of an excitement to get lyrics out or get music out, rhythm, melody, you know, sound, or was the initial draw more writing poetry, you know? Well, I think it's to get them to match, you know, so that the song is, you know, the song is the lyrics and the lyrics are just fit with the music, that the music means what the lyrics mean and the lyrics sound. So are you saying that rarely will there be a stack of lyrics on one side and a stack
那在早期就开始了，你知道，它还在继续。它仍然是不断移动的终点线，你知道，你每天都试图跨越它。是获取歌词更令人兴奋，还是获取音乐、节奏、旋律，你知道，声音，或者最初的吸引力更多是写诗，你知道？嗯，我认为是让它们匹配，你知道，这样这首歌是，你知道，这首歌是歌词，歌词只是与音乐相符，音乐意味着歌词的意思，歌词听起来。所以你是说很少会有堆积在一边的歌词和一堆
of cool sounding melodies and it's just arbitrary what set of lyrics go with what kind of song. In other words, are they written separately sometimes in your process and then you go, oh, these lyrics would go good with this sound or does it happen simultaneously? You know, every once in a while, because I will just sit and just write to write, just write to write and typewriters or calligraphy, whatever, I'll just write to write. And then I'll bring those notebooks and pads of paper and then something comes up and then I might think that this song sounds like that one thing I might have been writing about. So you might take the one line.
听起来很酷的旋律，而哪组歌词配哪种歌是随意的。换句话说，它们有时在你的过程中是分开写的，然后你说，哦，这些歌词配这个声音会很好，还是它们同时发生？你知道，偶尔，因为我会坐下来只是为了写而写，只是为了写而写，打字机或书法，无论什么，我只是为了写而写。然后我会带上那些笔记本和纸垫，然后出现了一些东西，然后我可能会认为这首歌听起来像我可能一直在写的那个东西。所以你可能会取那一行。
That's interesting. You might take two and then you flesh it out rarely would you take a whole page and just have it match up. So many of your lyrics are like just stuck with me and they always will be like I just know so many of them off by heart. They're kind of part of my experience, you know, especially in my sort of 20s and 30s, they were really just, they're so ingrained in my head. Like at any point, I can't, this is not a joke.
这很有趣。你可能会取两行，然后你充实它，很少你会拿整页纸然后让它匹配。你的很多歌词都深深印在我的脑海里，而且永远都会，就像我只是凭心记住了很多。它们就像是我经历的一部分，你知道，特别是在我 20 多岁和 30 多岁的时候，它们真的只是，它们深深地印在我的脑海里。就像在任何时候，我不能，这不是开玩笑。
I can't tell you how many times out of the blue, I will go alone, listless, like out of the blue, Eddie, it's crazy. And what's nuts is, and Jason kind of said, like, you know, your lyrics are, you are like, I don't want to embarrass you. You're like a poet though. And your lyrics do have, and I know that your songs have so much meaning. What was funny to us was a couple of weeks ago, we had David Byrne on the podcast and I was asking him about like, you know, you know, the song, all that lyrics are like,
我无法告诉你多少次突然之间，我会独自一人，无精打采，就像突然之间，埃迪，这太疯狂了。而且疯狂的是，杰森有点说，就像，你知道，你的歌词是，你是，我不想让你尴尬。你就像一个诗人。你的歌词确实有，而且我知道你的歌有很多意义。对我们来说有趣的是几周前，我们在播客上请到了大卫·伯恩（David Byrne），我问他关于，你知道，你知道，那首歌，所有那些歌词就像，
this is not your beautiful house. This is not your beautiful wife. I was like, whoa, what was that moment like? Like that, those lyrics are so important to so many people and they read into them and he was like, oh, it didn't mean anything. He said, he said, I was trying to sound like a preacher from AM Radio and I just kind of made it up and it has no meaning. And we were like, what?
这不是你美丽的房子。这不是你美丽的妻子。我当时想，哇，那一刻是什么感觉？就像，那些歌词对很多人来说太重要了，他们解读它们，而他就像，哦，那没有任何意义。他说，他说，我只是想听起来像一个来自 AM 电台的传教士，我只是编造了它，它没有任何意义。我们当时想，什么？
Because so many people have like, you know, really read into that shit. I have David Byrne lyrics that, you know, it's their one step short of being tattooed on my forearm. I mean, I lived, I've lived by them, you know, be a little more selfish. It might do you some good. Yeah, you know. Yeah, but to Will's point, Eddie, do you ever like, do you ever like actually let it in the fact that, because music is such a psychological thing for people that when you grow up or what
因为很多人真的解读了那些狗屁。我有大卫·伯恩的歌词，你知道，它们离纹在我的前臂上只差一步。我是说，我一直靠它们生活，你知道，自私一点。这可能对你有好处。是的，你知道。是的，但回到威尔的观点，埃迪，你有没有，你有没有真正接受这个事实，因为音乐对人们来说是一种心理上的东西，当你长大或者你听的东西成为你的一部分。你有没有真正沉浸其中，意识到你是那些创造了现在活在许多人心中的音乐和歌词的人之一？这真是一个令人难以置信的壮举。他在摇头。不，他在摇头。从不考虑那个。更多只是，更多是思考如果那个机会仍然存在，去做
you listen to becomes a part of who you are. And do you ever just really soak that in and realize you're one of those people that have created music and lyrics that now live inside so many people? It's kind of an unbelievable feat. He's shaking his head. No, he's shaking his head. Never think about that. It's more just, it's more thinking that if that opportunity still exists to still do
一些更好的事情，或者，你知道，当前的，或者，你知道，我觉得这些天，或者特别是过去几年，你知道，我依靠音乐，我们全家都依靠音乐，无论是举办舞会还是在一起录音等等。它一直是一件积极的事情，而且，你知道，我还在寻找。我需要音乐来度过难关，我希望能有音乐，你知道，为别人做同样的事情。也许吧。我会试试。
something better or, you know, current or, you know, I feel like these days or especially the last couple of years, you know, I've leaned on music, our whole family's leaned on music, whether it's been having dance parties or recording together or whatever. It's always been a positive thing and, you know, I'm still looking. I need music to get me through and I'd like to have music that may, you know, do the same for others. Maybe. I'll try.
你有没有发现，我知道你对名声和成功有一种爱恨交织的关系，就像大多数拥有令人钦佩的谦逊水平的人一样，但你有没有试过从那个成就袋里拿东西来帮助你度过一些非凡的压力或焦虑，比如，你知道，站在 10 万人面前，你正要走出去表演，比如，我想一个正常人需要从某种袋子里拿出某种骄傲，这样你就不会有焦虑症。所以至少用它来做那个，如果你在不需要的时候不会拍拍自己的背。
Do you ever find that, I know that you have a love-hate relationship with fame and success like most people with an admirable level of humility, but do you ever treat yourself to reaching into that bag of accomplishment to help you through some of the extraordinary levels of pressure or anxiety, like, you know, standing in front of 100,000 people, you're about to walk out and play, like, I would imagine a normal person would need to reach into some sort of bag of something, of some sort of pride so that you don't have an anxiety attack. So at least use it for that if you won't pat yourself on the back when you don't need it.
不，但你提到了一个好点。我应该那样做。是的，比如，在那里利用它没关系。是的。杰森，你拿的是什么袋子？你能在上面谈谈吗？它有一个拉链袋。不。
No, but you bring up a good point. I should do that. Yeah, like, that's okay to tap into it there. Yeah. Jason, what's the bag you reach into? Can you talk about it on here? It's got a ziplock. And no.
我想说这个。我想说，抱歉，只是结束歌词的事情，因为它真的让我受不了。对我来说，有史以来最令人心碎的歌词之一来自你的歌《Black》，我知道那是多年前的事了，埃迪，所以原谅我再次让你尴尬，但那句歌词说，我知道你总有一天会有美好的生活。我知道你会成为别人天空中的一颗星，但为什么不能是我天空中的一颗？这对我来说，说的是一个以如此深刻的方式理解痛苦和心碎的人。
I want to say this. I want to say, sorry, just wrap up the lyrics thing because it's just killing me. To me, one of the most sort of heartbreaking lyrics of all time is from your song Black, which I know as many years ago, Eddie, so forgive me for, again, embarrassing you, but there's that lyric that says, I know you'll have a beautiful life someday. I know you'll be a star in somebody else's sky, but why can it be in mine? That to me speaks of somebody who understands pain and heartbreak and stuff in a way that's so profound.
它如此诚实和揭示。你会开始哭吗，威尔？我会的，伙计。不，就像，那里面有一种脆弱，能够说出来，能够向某人传达这一点，我不知道，伙计，它真的说到了，我不知道你是否想谈论那个，或者那种写那样的歌词。它感觉暴露吗，或者它让你感到脆弱吗？嗯，Black，那是第一张唱片。
It's so honest and revealing. Would you start crying, Will? I'm gonna, man. No, it's like, there is a vulnerability in that, to be able to say that, to communicate that to somebody that, I don't know, man, it really speaks to, I don't know if you want to talk about that or that kind of writing a lyric like that. Does it feel exposing or does it make you feel vulnerable at all? Well, back, that was the first record.
所以没有人听我们的。所以没有理由，当我们录音时，没有理由认为我暴露了任何脆弱的一面。它真的只是在传达我的感受，或者说实话，再次，那是，那音乐，那哀伤的和弦变化等等，它听起来像心碎。所以，你知道，我认为其中一些可能基于事实或经验，但然后你围绕它创造一个故事，或者你创造，然后你目睹了这边发生的一些事情，然后你把它结合起来，你有点，但最后，你有了，它不仅仅是，
So we didn't have anybody listening to us. So there was no reason to, when we were recording, there was no reason to think that I was exposing any kind of vulnerable side. It was just really communicating what I was feeling or to be honest, again, that was something that, that music, that the plaintive chord changes and all that, it sounded like heartbreak. So, you know, I think some of it may be based in truth or experience, but then you create a story around that or you create, and then you witness some stuff going on over here and then you incorporate that and you kind of, but in the end, you had, it wasn't just,
你知道，男人唱那个，它是像男人和女人在唱。而且实际上，它有太多，你知道，那时我们的观众平均年龄是 19 岁左右。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。你们，你知道，创作了令人难以置信的摇滚乐，而且仍然在做，无论你想怎么称呼它，有，你知道，吉他驱动，它很硬，它是一个很棒的声音。然而你不害怕，你确实带来了这种，你知道，你们有点暴露
you know, men singing that, it was like men and women singing. And actually, it was so many, you know, back then our crowds were average age of 19 or something. We will be right back. And now back to the show. You guys, you know, made incredible and still do rock and roll music and rock, whatever you want to call it, there was, you know, guitar driven, it was hard, it was a great sound. And yet you weren't afraid, you did bring this kind of, you know, you guys kind of exposed
自己，以一种非常，我不知道，对你们来说非常容易接近的方式，因为它非常诚实，有一些东西，我认为这就是，你知道，你从一开始就与你的观众建立了联系。对我来说，我总是因为你们那种开放的方式而与你们的音乐产生共鸣。我喜欢你们不仅仅是，你知道，音乐往往，特别是硬摇滚音乐，非常，感觉非常男性主导。就像你说的，它感觉更具包容性。
yourself in this way that was very, I don't know, just really accessible to you guys, because it was very kind of honest, there was something, I think that that's, you know, you connected with your audience like right from the get. And for me, I always connected to your music because of the way you guys were so open in that way. I loved that you weren't just sort of, you know, music often times, especially kind of hard rock music, was very sort of, felt very male driven. And like you said, there's much more inclusive it felt like.
你知道，我一直有点嫉妒这个乐队 Mudhoney 的歌手和歌词作者马克·哈曼（Mark Harman），因为它是如此尖刻，感觉如此，他的歌词在向外推动和激励，对我来说感觉他只是被保护了，你知道，就像伊基·波普（Iggy Pop）或者科特（Kurt）也是，他的歌词晦涩而强硬，有时甚至不确定他在唱什么，或者迈克尔·斯泰普（Michael Stipe）就像被某种神秘的面纱保护着。我一直，我一直希望我当时能做得更好，但这只是我写作或感受的方式，或者，你知道，我真的，说实话，我不知道
You know, I was always a little bit envious of the singer and writer of lyrics in this band Mudhoney, Mark Harman, because it was so acerbic and felt so, his lyrics were pushing outward and galvanized and it felt to me like he was just protected, you know, it was like Iggy Pop or and Kurt too, his lyrics were cryptic and tough and weren't even sure sometimes what he was singing about or Michael Stipe was like protected in some kind of shroud of mystery. And I always, I always wished I was better at that at the time, but it was just the way that I was writing or feeling or, you know, I really, to be honest, I didn't know what
我在做什么，至于，你知道，如果有人听到它会发生什么，因为我们只是没想到真的会有人，不是，不是像最终听到它的那么多人，这可能让第二张唱片在歌词上更难，因为那时你确实有了，也许人们在听，或者它会被听到和批评，那可能是歌词上最难克服的一张，而且仍然要确定，而不是对未来的反应做出反应，你知道，是的，是的，是的，所有那些专辑都太棒了，你制作了那么多，现在是个人作品，在中间完成它。
I was doing as far as, you know, what would happen if anybody heard it, because we just didn't think anybody really would not not not like as many people has ended up hearing it, which maybe probably made the second record a little tougher, because then you did have the thing of, of maybe people were listening, or that it would be heard and criticized and and that was probably the hardest one to get through lyrically and still have it be sure and not reacting to the future reaction, you know, yeah, yeah, yeah, all those albums are just so good and you've made so many of them and and now the solo effort, getting that done in between.
你现在的生活中有什么主导的东西吗，我敢打赌是家庭，以及通常只是我们有变老的特权，因为唯一的选择是死亡，你开始吸收很多不同的东西。这就是推动你声音变化的原因吗，在某种程度上确实有变化。我是说，我知道我肯定它与你们在乐队里做的有很大不同，但什么是推动现在听起来对你来说不错的东西，以及你正在写的东西的主要东西？你知道，我想我去了洛杉矶参加一个叫 Vax Live 的活动。
Is there a dominant thing in your life now, I'll bet it's family and just generally just us having the privilege of getting older because the only other alternative is death and you're starting to absorb a lot of different things. Is that what's fueling your change in sound to the extent that there that there is one. I mean, I know I'm sure it's vastly different than what you guys do with the band, but what is what's the main thing that's driving what sounds good to you nowadays and what you're writing about? You know, I think I went down to Los Angeles to participate in something called Vax Live.
它是由 Global Citizen 举办的，很多伟大的人聚在一起鼓励人们接种疫苗，就在机会被提供的时候，并鼓励制药公司等向第三世界国家提供疫苗等等。所以这是一个伟大的努力，然后我碰巧遇到了一个我多年来认识的人，叫安德鲁·瓦特（Andrew Watt），某种制作人音乐家，我们做了一段时间的朋友，或者只是熟人，我只是想去看看录音室，我们待了几天，立刻就开始写歌了。所以我认为是什么在影响这些新东西，只是一个新的合作者，一个新的录音室
It was put on by Global Citizen and a lot of great people coming together to encourage people to vaccinate right when the opportunity was being afforded and encouraging pharmaceutical companies, etc. to make the vaccinations available to third world countries, etc. So it was a great endeavor and and then I just happened to bump into a guy that I had come to know over the years a bit named Andrew Watt and kind of producer musician and we've been friends for a while or just kind of acquaintances and I just wanted to go see a studio and and we hung out for a couple days and just immediately started writing. So I think what was informing some of this new stuff was just a new collaborator, a new studio
这是一个有点家庭自制的地下室，只是和另一个人乔什·克林霍夫（Josh Klinghofer）一起工作，他一直在和我们的团队合作，当我们出去现场演奏新唱片时，那是两年前，我们还没有巡演。等不及了。叫 Gigaton。所以，所以乔什在其中，我们只是开始聚在一起，然后，然后我们实际上，它进行得太顺利了，我们让其他人也下来了，然后我们也开始做一些真正的果酱歌曲，就在这种新的氛围和新的感觉中，而且进行得非常好
which is a little home kind of spun basement and just working with some another guy, Josh Klinghofer, which has been working with our group with the when we go out live playing the new record, which was two years ago, which we haven't toured on yet. Can't wait for that. Called Gigaton. So so Josh was in the fold and we just started hanging out and then and then we actually it was going so well we had the rest of the guys come down and then we started doing some real jam songs as well just in this new atmosphere and new feeling and and that went really well
也是。所以我认为走出 COVID，它就像是对所有孤立的解毒剂。但什么在影响你现在的品味？是，是你的感性，主要是随着你的家庭动态和你的节奏调整的吗？我想，嗯，当然那是结构的一部分，你知道，你知道，没有什么比成为父母更能让你感到成熟了。是的。
too. So I think coming out of COVID it was it was like an antidote to all the isolation. But what's affecting your taste nowadays? Is it is it your sensibilities of being adjusted mostly with your with your with your family dynamic and your tempo there? I think well, certainly that's part of the fabric, you know, of, you know, nothing makes you feel more grown up and being a parent. Yeah.
而且现在有了孩子，你知道，正在成为年轻人。而且它还没有到那里，这是一个坏蛋女人的房子。所以，你知道，我认为它来自谦逊和责任的地方，并且总是照顾，你知道，她们的世界。让我问你一些关于，我正要说，埃迪，抱歉，肖恩，就在你之前，我知道你提到你喜欢你的伙伴有一个小地下室录音室。我是在我新的小地下室录音室里，随时。埃迪，我只是知道我不想让你尴尬，肖恩，杰森，别插手。
And having kids now that are, you know, becoming young adults. And it's not already there and it's a house of badass women. So, you know, I think it comes from in place of humility and responsibility and always looking out for, you know, their world. Let me ask you something just about I was going to say, Eddie, sorry, Sean, just before you, I know that you mentioned that you like your buddy had a little basement studio. That's I'm in my new little basement studio anytime. Eddie, I just know I don't want to embarrass you, Sean, Jason, stay out of it.
是的。埃迪，随时，伙计。我有一个小声乐区。看那个环境有多鼓舞人心。一个麦克风。他都准备好了。我也有两个麦克风。抱歉。
Yeah. Eddie, anytime, man. I got like a little vocal area. Look how inspiring that environment is. One microphone. He's all set up. I got two microphones too. Sorry.
我转向他。是的，伙计。你知道吗？好吧，我要送你去看那块空白的地方。是的。我要送你一个带支架的好尤克里里。把它放在那里。是的。
I turned to him. Yeah, man. You know what? Well, I'm going to send you to see that blank space right there. Yeah. I'm going to send you a nice ukulele with a holder. Just put it right there. Yes.
我想我应该送你们所有人尤克里里。看，杰森，你有一个放尤克里里的空间。就在那里。就在那里。带上它。杰森会送你一张签名的头像照。是的。我可以为你签一张 8x10 的。
I think I should send you all of ukulele. Look, Jason, you got a space for ukulele. Right there. Right there. Bring it. Jason will send you a signed headshot. Yeah. I can sign a eight by 10 for you.
很高兴能在那上面。是的。你看起来像 Oakwood 公司住房的干洗店。但说到那个，你刚才指着墙上的吉他。你，我甚至不知道你会弹多少种乐器？你希望你会弹哪一种乐器？我希望我会弹，我是说，我可以，我可以从一把小提琴里发出声音，但我希望我真的能弹奏它，或者也许是大提琴，就像一种无品弦乐器
Happy to be right up there. Yeah. You look like the dry cleaners of the Oakwood corporate housing. But speaking about that, you just pointed to your guitars on your wall. Do you, I don't even know how many instruments do you play? And what's the one instrument that you don't that you wish you did? I wish I could play, I mean, I can make, I can get a sound out of a violin, but I wish I could actually really play one or maybe a cello, like a fretless stringed instrument
用弓拉的那种。那是因为你喜欢古典音乐吗？不，但我不介意。但我认为你可以。当然。背景里很好。你可以做一些有趣的。我是这个家伙沃伦·埃利斯（Warren Ellis）的忠实粉丝，他和尼克·凯夫（Nick Cave）和坏种子乐队（Bad Seeds）一起演奏，还有
with a bow would be. Is that because you love classical music? No, but I don't mind it. But I think you could. Sure. It's fine in the background. You could do some interesting. I'm a big fan of this guy, Warren Ellis, who plays with Nick Cave and the Bad Seeds and
只是尼克·凯夫。沃伦过去有一个叫 The Dirty Three 的乐队，在过去都是纯器乐。我们差点把这个播客叫那个名字。那太棒了。The Dirty Three。顺便说一句，那会很好。但他们令人难以置信。而且全是即兴创作。
just Nick Cave. And Warren had a band called The Dirty Three, which was all instrumental back in the day. And we almost called this podcast that. That's amazing. The Dirty Three. By the way, it would have been good. But they were incredible. And it was all improvisational.
他一直是我一生中巨大的灵感来源。所以随着时间的推移，你知道，珍珠果酱乐队，我想是在 80 年代末 90 年代初成立的，对吧？或者类似那样。90，91，是的。是的。随着时间的推移，音乐周围的技术进步，那有帮助吗？那有阻碍吗？
And he's been a huge inspiration to me all of my life. So was there as time went on, you know, Pearl Jam, I think was formed around late 80s, early 90s, right? Or something like that. 90, 91, yeah. Yeah. And as time went on and technology improved around music, did that help? Did that hinder?
你拥抱它了吗？你当时是，去他的？我们全是原声的？那有以任何方式影响你吗？我们是模拟的。我们是模拟的。我认为，我认为技术很棒。我仍然，我的目标一直是，或者我认为团队有点同意，使用技术来
Did you embrace it? Were you like, screw that? Were all acoustic? Like did that influence you in any way? We're analog. We're analog. I think that I think technology is great. I still, my goal has been, or I think the group kind of agrees, using the technology to
做我们一直做的事情，但也许更有效率或更快。说实话，如果你不直接录到磁带上，比如两英寸磁带，像我们过去模拟的那样，等等，它可能听起来没那么好。但我只是认为你会在技术中迷失。所以，但是如果你能梳理它并提炼技术来做你过去用旧东西做的简单事情，我只是觉得没有什么能真正让音乐比演奏得好和写得好更好。而且你可以用任何东西做到这一点，所以我们不需要所有额外的东西。
do what we've always done, but maybe do it more efficiently or quicker. And to be honest, it probably doesn't sound quite as good if you don't do it right onto tape, like two inch tape, like we used to analog, et cetera. But I just think you can get lost in the technology. And so, but if you can comb through it and distill the technology to do the simple things that you used to do with the old stuff, I just feel like nothing can really make the music better than just playing well and writing well. And that you can do with anything so we don't need all the extra stuff.
但你可以使用技术让它快一点，有时听起来好一点。所以你们没有感到任何压力去跟上我似乎看到的某种趋势，即这种电子声音与更传统的放大器、音乐、吉他的融合。你听起来从来没有这么老过，杰森。我知道。你听起来从来没有比这一刻更脱节了。
But you can use the technology to just make it go a little quicker and maybe sound a little bit better sometime. So you guys don't feel any pressure to sort of keep up with what I seem to see as somewhat of a trend where this integration of electronic sound with the more sort of traditional sort of amplifier, music, guitar. You've never sounded older, Jason. I know. You've never sounded more out of touch than this moment.
而且你听起来脱节很多次了。我会说出我听的其他两个乐队，Radiohead 和 Wilco，他们采用某种电子声音，并将其注入到一些，那是你们会玩的东西吗？你们觉得有义务吗？这对你们来说有趣吗？我想如果我更擅长它，我想有时我会受到启发去做那个。然后这需要阅读手册并弄清楚如何操作这些旋钮。
And you've sounded out of touch a lot. I'll name the two other groups I listened to, Radiohead and Wilco, where they take sort of an electronic sound and they infuse it into some of the, is that something that you guys play around with? Do you feel obligated to? Is it interesting to you? I think if I was better at it, I think sometimes I'd be inspired to do that. And then that entails reading like manuals and figuring out how to work these knobs.
我会买这个。我会读关于 Radiohead 的 Ed O'Brien 使用的吉他踏板，或者我会看他使用它，然后意识到你需要花很多时间弄清楚旋钮是做什么的。我想要，我宁愿写作或做一些我可以写的东西。是的。嘿，埃迪，我忘了问你。我能很快问你吗？我一直回去，就像，哦，伙计，我一直，因为这些是我一直想要的
And I'll buy this. I'll read about a guitar pedal that Ed O'Brien from Radiohead used, or I'd watch him use it and then realize that you need to spend a lot of time figuring out what the knobs do. And I wanted, I'd rather be writing or doing something that I could write about. Yeah. Hey, Eddie, I forgot to ask you. Can I just ask you really quick? I keep going back like, oh, man, I've always, because these are things I've always wanted
我会买这个。我会去读关于电台司令乐队的艾德·奥布莱恩使用的吉他效果器的文章，或者看他使用它，然后意识到你需要花很多时间去弄清楚旋钮的功能。我想要的是，我宁愿去写作或者做一些我能写下来的事情。对了，艾迪，我忘了问你了。我能快速问你一下吗？我一直回想，天哪，我一直，因为这些都是我一直想要的东西
to talk to you about because we only talked to each other for like 90 seconds. Well, I'm so happy to be talking to you now. Yeah. 15 years ago. He's been waiting since that phone call. I got my list out. I have like a whole Eddie file. But God bless you.
和你聊聊，因为我们之前只聊了大概90秒。好吧，我现在很高兴能和你交谈。是啊。15年前。他从那通电话起就一直在等。我把我的清单拿出来了。我有一个完整的埃迪档案。但上帝保佑你。
Lighten up a name. Oh, he's smoking. Well, he's smoking. Go ahead. I don't smoke in my studio. This is breakfast. Why not? Well, if you're going to have Eddie over there, you're going to have to allow smoking.
放轻松点。哦，他在抽烟。好吧，他在抽烟。请便。我的录音室里不抽烟。这是早餐时间。为什么不呢？好吧，如果你要让埃迪在那儿，你就得允许抽烟。
Of course he can. He was kidding. So hang on. So I don't know what year it was, but you and a guy who I've known for a long time, Bill Janowitz from Buffalo, Tom. You know Bill. I love Bill. Great guy.
当然可以。他开玩笑的。等等。我不知道那是哪一年，但你和一个我认识很久的人，来自布法罗的比尔·亚诺维茨，汤姆。你认识比尔。我爱比尔。很棒的人。
Great guy and great band. And you guys played their song. Taillight's Fate, yeah. Oh my God. Have you guys, Sean and Jason, have you guys seen that? Taillight's Fate to Black. No. Have not.
很棒的人，很棒的乐队。你们演奏了他们的歌。《Taillight's Fate》，是的。天哪。肖恩和杰森，你们看过那个吗？《Taillight's Fate to Black》。没有。没看过。
I want to say it now. Can I YouTube that? That was cool, right? You were in Boston doing that where everybody, you know, and you guys knew the song. I mean, did you and Bill know each other for a while or what was the deal? I think we played one show with them, I think in Boston back in maybe 91. And I had already had their record or CD at that time. And that song used to hit me and I remember the first time we ever had a tour bus and looking
我现在想说。我能在YouTube上搜吗？那很酷，对吧？你在波士顿做那个的时候，每个人，你知道的，你们都知道那首歌。我是说，你和比尔认识很久了吗？还是怎么回事？我想我们和他们一起演出过一场，大概是在91年的波士顿。那时我已经有他们的唱片或CD了。那首歌曾经触动过我，我记得我们第一次有巡演巴士时，看着
out the window and feeling very tragic amongst all the newfound success and having that song really hit me. And then years later, I used the word Taillight's in one of my songs. Next time I saw Bill, I said, hey, you know, I was going to call you, but I used that. I used Taillight's and I apologized and he says, oh, don't worry about it. He goes, you know, I got it from Keith Richards. So what is the song about before they make me run, I think, either that or when the whip comes down, something about Taillight's Fate, but yeah.
窗外，在所有新获得的成功中感到非常悲伤，那首歌真的触动了我。后来几年，我在我的一首歌里用了“Taillight's”这个词。下次见到比尔时，我说，嘿，你知道吗，我本来想给你打电话的，但我用了那个词。我用了“Taillight's”，我道歉了，他说，哦，别担心。他说，你知道，我是从基思·理查兹那里听来的。那首歌是关于什么的？我想是在《Before They Make Me Run》之前，或者是《When the Whip Comes Down》，关于《Taillight's Fate》的，但确实是。
Wow. Why do I remember you in a Red Sox cap? Is that a cap you wear often? Are you a Red Sox fan? You're a baseball fan, aren't you? I have an affinity to the Red Sox and partly because of the history and the glory of that old building, which is Fenway Park. And then I grew up at Wrigley Field.
哇。为什么我记得你戴着红袜队的帽子？那是你经常戴的帽子吗？你是红袜队的球迷吗？你是棒球迷，对吧？我对红袜队有一种好感，部分是因为那座老建筑——芬威球场的历史和荣耀。我是在瑞格利球场长大的。
So the old buildings and baseball and the smaller feel are kind of in my DNA. And then the third oldest ballpark is Dodger Stadium. That's right. My beloved. So yeah, so it's the Cubs that are your, that's your team. Yeah, but I feel like I can like the Red Sox because it's American League, you know. Yeah, yeah, I got you. Talk to me about the difference between recording in a studio where you guys have multiple tracks
所以那些老建筑、棒球和那种小巧的感觉就像在我的基因里一样。第三古老的球场是道奇体育场。没错。我的挚爱。所以，是的，小熊队是你的球队。是的，但我感觉我可以喜欢红袜队，因为那是美国联盟的，你知道的。是的，是的，我明白。跟我说说在录音室录音和你们一起现场演奏的区别，在录音室里你们有多轨录音，
and you can really dial in, you can do your vocals a million times once the music is laid down or vice versa, I'm not sure what the, what the sequencing is there versus when you get together as a group and you play live and you know that you're, there's no net under you guys and you're feeling and hearing the momentum and the sound of the music at the same time the audience is. Do you leave yourself open to a completely different experience there and allow the audience to drive and inform the mood there, what songs, what order you're going to play, how you're going to play them?
你可以真正地进行微调，音乐录好后你可以录一百万次人声，或者反过来，我不确定顺序是什么，而当你们作为一个团队聚在一起现场演奏时，你知道没有安全网，你们同时感受和听到音乐的动力和声音，观众也是。你们会让自己去体验一种完全不同的经历，让观众来驱动和影响情绪，决定唱什么歌，什么顺序，怎么演奏吗？
Is it participatory like that or is it pretty siloed? No, for sure. I mean, that's what makes our job harder, but we've done it to ourselves and that's what people like to, apparently like to see us more than once or more than once in a weekend or more or 10 times on a tour or something because all the shows are different and I think that comes, we have our crew, we've just been a big family for 30 years and you know if I were to do the same thing twice they would know it and I like to entertain, we like to keep them entertained and on their toes and I think they respect that and that
是那种参与式的，还是相当孤立的？不，当然不是。我是说，这让我们的工作更难，但这是我们自找的，这就是为什么人们似乎喜欢不止一次，或者一个周末看我们不止一次，或者巡演看我们10次之类的，因为所有的演出都不一样，我认为这来自于，我们有我们的团队，我们30年来一直是一个大家庭，你知道如果我做同样的事情两次，他们会知道的，我喜欢娱乐，我们喜欢让他们保持娱乐，保持警觉，我认为他们尊重这一点，而且
level of respect and feeling like we're all part of it and everyone's going to have to be on point for the whole night is part of why we can make changes or we do things I call audibles for feeling something's happening or the other thing is being able to stop a show. Yeah. Have you ever cut a show short because the audience wasn't as responsive as you'd like or didn't come back for an encore because you're like, you know what? We're good.
那种尊重感，感觉我们都是其中的一部分，每个人整晚都必须保持专注，这就是为什么我们可以做出改变，或者我们做一些我称之为“临场应变”的事情，如果我们感觉到发生了什么，或者另一件事是能够叫停演出。是的。你有没有因为观众反应不如预期，或者没有返场而缩短过演出，因为你觉得，你知道吗？我们够了。
You know what, Sean? They don't deserve it. I shouldn't say this, but we probably end up playing longer on those nights because we're going to get them. We're not leaving until we fucking get them. I get that vibe. I get that. Is there a city that's tougher than others or a country that's tougher than others and
你知道吗，肖恩？他们不配。我不该这么说，但我们可能在那些晚上反而演奏得更久，因为我们要征服他们。不搞定他们我们绝不离开。我懂那种感觉。我懂。有没有哪个城市比其他地方更难搞，或者哪个国家更难搞，
the opposite as well? Is there an easy lay somewhere? Well, if I could take it out of that vernacular. Please do. Yeah. Please save Jason from himself. The crowds in South America are just, they will sing guitar solos. They will sing in unison.
反之亦然？有没有哪里比较容易？好吧，如果我能换个说法的话。请便。是的。请把杰森从他自己手中拯救出来。南美洲的观众简直是，他们会跟着唱吉他独奏。他们会齐声合唱。
100,000 people will sing the guitar solo. That's great. They'll also, there'll be 5,000 people outside of your hotel room at one in the morning singing the song and singing the guitar solos. That's great. I'll bet you LA and New York are tough crowds. They used to be. Yeah.
10万人会一起唱吉他独奏。那太棒了。他们还会，凌晨一点会有5000人在你的酒店房间外唱歌，唱那首歌，唱吉他独奏。那太棒了。我敢打赌洛杉矶和纽约是很难搞的观众。过去是。是的。
I think they used to be. And I think back in the day, we were more concerned about that or look, we were spoiled at some point. So if people weren't being riled up, we'd want to rile them up even more or something. But I just don't think we care about that as much anymore. And we're there to just play well. And I mean, we're there to, you know, communicate and the other thing is making a big room feel small and intimate.
我想过去是。我想在过去，我们更关心那个，或者看，我们在某种程度上被宠坏了。所以如果人们没有被煽动起来，我们会想更进一步煽动他们之类的。但我只是觉得我们现在没那么在意了。我们去那里只是为了演奏好。我是说，我们去那里是为了，你知道，交流，另一件事是让大场地感觉小而亲密。
And that's always kind of the goal. And you just never know what can happen and creating a space where other things can happen. It could be some kind of crowd interaction or some interaction within the band. But just being open to that and grabbing it as opposed to having like a scripted out thing, which would kind of be amazing. You could do longer tours if you just kind of knew that you got up at two, you had a workout, you went to soundcheck, you did the set, you went home, you did the same thing the next night.
这总是我们的目标。你永远不知道会发生什么，创造一个其他事情可以发生的空间。可能是某种观众互动，或者是乐队内部的互动。但要对这些保持开放，抓住它们，而不是像有一个写好的剧本，那会很神奇。如果你知道两点起床，锻炼，去试音，做演出，回家，第二天做同样的事情，你可以进行更长的巡演。
I mean, you could really fit in a lot of shows. It would be easier. Got up at two in the afternoon. That's a wake up at two in the afternoon. Well, because you stay up until five in the morning, you see. Good Lord. This is a good tough question. It's like, do you have a show or experience or a festival or like a moment that you felt
我是说，你真的可以安排很多演出。那会更容易。下午两点起床。那是下午两点起床。好吧，因为你熬夜到凌晨五点，你看。天哪。这是一个很好的难题。就像，你有没有一场演出或经历，或者一个音乐节，或者一个时刻，你觉得
like was kind of that kind of rose above there. You just felt so connected and you're like, you look back on and go like that moment. That's the one I'm going to chase. I mean, it kind of happens a lot, you know. Yeah. Same. Shut up, Will. No.
那种感觉升华了，你感到如此紧密相连，你回首往事说，那一刻。那是我要追寻的。我是说，这种情况经常发生，你知道。是的。我也是。闭嘴，威尔。不。
Eddie and I are both artists. Shut up. We're artists and you're a robot. Have you ever seen promises promises? It was on Broadway. Have you ever seen Sean in promises promises? Have you ever gotten scared because you opened your mouth and because you were getting sick, nothing came out or, you know, you had no voice or whatever caused you to do a lesser
埃迪和我都是艺术家。闭嘴。我们是艺术家，而你是机器人。你看过《Promises Promises》吗？那是百老汇的剧。你看过肖恩演的《Promises Promises》吗？你有没有因为张嘴而感到害怕，因为你生病了，什么声音都发不出来，或者，你知道，你没有声音，或者任何导致你表现得
performance than you hoped for. And what did you do and how did you handle it? Well, I used to stress out about that stuff more, but now I think it's just, you know, relax, get through it. You know, there's things you can do. Well, you would know. You can change your breathing. You can do certain things to get it out or maybe you have to sing one certain line at
不如预期的情况？你做了什么，你是怎么处理的？好吧，我过去确实会为那些事情感到压力，但现在我想，只是，你知道，放松，熬过去。你知道，有些事情你可以做。好吧，你会知道的。你可以改变呼吸。你可以做某些事情来发出声音，或者也许你必须用
a lower or do a harmony octave or something. Or just talk it. Or Jeremy spoke up in class today. Point the microphone at the audience. Is that what you were going to say? You do the, yeah, let them do it. Hey, you guys do it. Right.
更低的声音唱某一行，或者做和声八度之类的。或者干脆说出来。或者杰里米今天在课堂上发言了。把麦克风指向观众。你是想说这个吗？你做那个，是的，让他们做。嘿，你们来做。对吧。
Yeah. I went to, this is like three, four years ago, I went to Berlin with the guys from U2 and with Bono and Edge and those guys, and I went to see them do a show. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. What do you mean you went to Berlin with U2? You're on the plane? I wasn't on the plane. I met them there, but I was hanging with Edge and Bono in the South of France.
是的。我去了，这是三四年前的事了，我和U2的伙计们，还有波诺和Edge他们一起去了柏林，我去看他们的演出。哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。你是说你和U2一起去了柏林？你在飞机上？我不在飞机上。我在那里见他们，但我之前和Edge还有波诺在法国南部待过。
They lived in the South. And I was working down there, as you know, and we were hanging out. They're great guys. They're great. They're great. They're great. So we go, baby, and that is drippiest. Oh, are they?
他们住在南部。我当时在那里工作，如你所知，我们在一起玩。他们是很棒的人。他们很棒。他们很棒。他们很棒。所以我们去吧，宝贝，那是最棒的。哦，是吗？
So anyway, so you're on tour with U2. Go ahead. I met them at the show, but we're, you know, whatever we were up. So anyway, I go to the show, Bono loses his voice. Like three songs in that show. I was at that show. Oh, and you took over. And I took over and I gotta give the audience what they want.
所以不管怎样，你和U2一起巡演。继续。我在演出时见到他们，但我们，你知道，不管我们当时在干嘛。所以不管怎样，我去看演出，波诺失声了。演出才三首歌。我在那场演出。哦，然后你接手了。我接手了，我必须给观众他们想要的。
And people didn't notice. Wait, what happened to Bono? Was he sick? They canceled the show, man. It was almost like he inhaled like a chemical or a smoke thing. And it just shut down his vocal cords. It just, that's what I heard. Yeah.
人们没注意到。等等，波诺怎么了？他生病了吗？他们取消了演出，伙计。就像他吸入了某种化学物质或烟雾一样。这直接关闭了他的声带。就是这样，我听到的。是的。
That's exactly right. They had this new smoke. The people who were doing the, whatever, does that fall under pyro? I guess or whatever. But scary though, right? I mean, those are those, I've had that moment too. Like as, because we all performed where you go like, oh, shit. Is this the thing?
完全正确。他们有这种新烟雾。那些做，不管是什么的人，那属于烟火吗？我猜或者别的什么。但很吓人，对吧？我是说，那些是，我也经历过那一刻。就像，因为我们都表演过，你会想，哦，该死。是这个吗？
Yeah. Is this the moment? You know what I mean? Eddie, what is the guns to your head? You can only do one thing for the rest of your life between the two, making music or surfing? Making music. Okay.
是的。是这一刻吗？你知道我的意思吗？埃迪，枪指着你的头，余生你只能做一件事，在两者之间选择，做音乐还是冲浪？做音乐。好的。
But you do love the surfing. I've, I've, you know, look, I'm, I'm at an age where I can't serve as big waves as I used to. And so I've had my fill and I've got a couple of nice pictures of me on big waves. Do you get out there with Larry Hamilton at all? I used to. Yeah. I haven't seen him in a while.
但你确实喜欢冲浪。我，我，你知道，看，我到了一个不能再冲大浪的年纪了。所以我已经满足了，我有几张我在大浪上的漂亮照片。你和莱尔德·汉密尔顿一起出去过吗？我过去常去。是的。我有一阵子没见他了。
But yeah, he, you know, he invented so many of the things that people now do on the water. You know, he'd invent something, you know, stand up, he'd invent toe and surfing with his friends and then move on to something else and then invent standup paddle and then move on to something else. Now he's foiling where he's, you know, three feet off the water and foiling through it. So we, I've been lucky enough to be with him and be taught by him. Yeah. What, what is it?
但是的，他，你知道，他发明了许多人们现在在水上做的事情。你知道，他会发明一些东西，你知道，站立式，他和朋友们发明了拖曳冲浪，然后转向别的东西，然后发明了站立式桨板，然后转向别的东西。现在他在玩水翼，你知道，离水面三英尺，在水上滑行。所以我们，我有幸和他在一起，并受教于他。是的。什么，什么？
If the, if the waves are X amount of feet high, that's too high for you to paddle out. What is it? Well, nowadays I would say, you know, I'm not going to, a 12 foot wave is a lot of water. Good God. But, you know, I've been on. Charlotte Jason, Charlotte, have you surfed? No, look at me. No.
如果浪高X英尺，那对你来说太高了，不能划出去。是什么？好吧，现在我会说，你知道，我不会，12英尺的浪是很多水。天哪。但是，你知道，我经历过。夏洛特·杰森，夏洛特，你们冲过浪吗？没有，看看我。没有。
No, I know. Jack Johnson is the best surfing musician. Oh really? I mean, he grew up right there at Pipeline. He's incredible and great, great person, great family. Now, have you, have you done the Laird Hamilton workout with him in the pool there? I have, yeah. That stuff.
没有，我知道。杰克·约翰逊是最好的冲浪音乐家。哦，真的吗？我是说，他在Pipeline那里长大。他很不可思议，很棒的人，很棒的家庭。现在，你和他在那里的游泳池里做过莱尔德·汉密尔顿的训练吗？我做过，是的。那些东西。
Can you explain to our listener what that is? What is that? It's just a series of exercises that you do underwater thinking that, you know, you're getting used to your body under duress, underwater. So when you, you know, it applies to surfing. And so you, if you have like a major wipe out, you're used to like battling underwater. And it might just be, you know, you have a swim mask on and you're carrying some weights and you hold your breath and then you just do laps under the pool.
你能向我们的听众解释那是什么吗？那是什么？这只是一系列你在水下做的练习，认为，你知道，你正在习惯身体在压力下，在水下。所以当你，你知道，它适用于冲浪。所以你，如果你有一次严重的翻船，你习惯了在水下挣扎。它可能只是，你知道，你戴着游泳面罩，带着一些重量，你屏住呼吸，然后在游泳池里游几圈。
You know, you'd see if you can do a couple laps or be under for 90 seconds, then come up and get another breath and then do more. Or you just, you go to the deep end and you push yourself up, get a breath, go down, push yourself up, get a breath, go down. The cool thing is the heavier the weights, the faster you go down. So that's kind of nice. And that's just, you know, they used to do it years ago that the Hawaiians would go swim down, pick up a big rock, you know, run for 30 yards and then come up and get a breath
你知道，你会看看你能不能游几圈，或者在水下待90秒，然后上来换口气，然后再做更多。或者你只是，你去深水区，把自己推上去，换口气，下去，把自己推上去，换口气，下去。酷的是重量越重，你下去得越快。所以那挺好的。那只是，你知道，他们过去常做，夏威夷人会游下去，捡起一块大石头，你知道，跑30码，然后上来换口气
and then do laps. Just to train themselves. So Larry's probably the closest thing to a human fish we have today. Would you say that? Human Kelly Slater. Yeah. Yeah, they're Kelly Slater. Great golfer.
然后游几圈。只是为了训练自己。所以莱尔德可能是我们今天最接近人类鱼类的人。你会这么说吗？人类凯利·斯莱特。是的。是的，他们是凯利·斯莱特。伟大的高尔夫球手。
Great golfer. Do you play, do you play golf, Eddie? I do not. All right. You know what, Eddie? I don't either. Eddie, were you doing the, were you doing the cold plunge stuff too? Did you get into that?
伟大的高尔夫球手。你打高尔夫吗，埃迪？我不打。好吧。你知道吗，埃迪？我也不打。埃迪，你也在做冷水浸泡吗？你开始尝试了吗？
He's, he's, he's an expert at that. I've got the Puget Sound so I can jump into that and that's, that's fairly cold. I might someday. I feel like I haven't needed it quite yet, but I'm certainly getting there. Just take a cold shower. I love it, man. I do that cold thing too. I'm super into it.
他，他，他是那方面的专家。我有普吉特海湾，所以我可以跳进去，那，那相当冷。我可能有一天会。我觉得我还没完全需要它，但我肯定快了。洗个冷水澡就行。我喜欢，伙计。我也做那种冷水的东西。我非常喜欢。
And we will be right back. All right. Back to the show. I want to know, Eddie, you've worked, you worked with so many people, legendary, huge names, too many to list. Is there anybody you haven't worked with that's on your dream list? Outside of you. You've got an appointment with Will at the studio.
我们马上回来。好的。回到节目。我想知道，埃迪，你工作过，你和很多人合作过，传奇的，巨大的名字，多到列举不完。有没有谁是你还没合作过但在你的梦想名单上的？除了你。你和威尔在录音室有个预约。
You know, it's just this life and music. Grow would tell you the same thing if he hasn't already. It's just been such a, such a huge, incredible blessing and growing up loving music just about more than anything. And then knowing the music and then getting to know the people that made it and inspired you to begin with. And then when you're, then when you become, you know, close friends, that's, that's just a whole another level of, then it, then it kind of changes.
你知道，这就是生活和音乐。格罗也会告诉你同样的事情，如果他还没告诉你的话。这真是一个，一个巨大的，不可思议的祝福，从小就爱音乐胜过一切。然后了解音乐，然后认识那些创作音乐并最初激励你的人。然后当你，然后当你成为，你知道，亲密的朋友，那，那又是另一个层次了，然后它，然后它就变了。
Then, then you're just friends. And now you don't even think that that's, you have to kind of remind yourself that, oh, that's, that's the guy that kind of raised you musically. That's what Jason and Will think of me. Can you talk about your, your, your co, your co-bandmate on, on Mrs. Mills? Yeah, I sent, I sent Jason a song yesterday. It'll be out in February with the rest of the collection of this new stuff. On Earthling.
然后，然后你们只是朋友。现在你甚至不会想到，你得提醒自己，哦，那是那个在音乐上养育你的人。这就是杰森和威尔对我的看法。你能谈谈你的，你的，你的乐队伙伴，在《Mrs. Mills》上吗？是的，我昨天给杰森发了一首歌。它将在二月和这批新东西的其余部分一起发布。在《Earthling》上。
Let's listen to a clip. But you had a special, special guest star there on Mrs. Mills. The song asked for it. And it was a song about a piano. And there's a song, a piano, and it resides at Abbey Road. And it was interesting to hear that Paul McCartney tried to purchase it to have it. Because I think it was like the Lady Madonna piano. A lot of songs were, and they called it Mrs. Mills because it was left behind by a woman,
让我们听一段片段。但你在《Mrs. Mills》上有一位特别的，特别的客串明星。这首歌要求这么做。这是一首关于钢琴的歌。有一首歌，一架钢琴，它存放在艾比路录音室。听到保罗·麦卡特尼试图买下它很有趣。因为我想那是《Lady Madonna》的钢琴。很多歌都是，他们叫它“Mrs. Mills”，因为它是一个女人留下的，
Gladys Mills, who used to write kind of English pub songs and sing-alongs. And her piano was left and they call it Mrs. Mills. And it's still there because they, they refused to sell it to Paul. And, and we had our own Mrs. Mills in California, the same model, Steinway. And the guy I was working with, Andrew, he had Elton John in there playing Mrs. Mills. Paul came in and played Mrs. Mills because they recorded a song together. And we did a couple songs and he played the shit out of Mrs. Mills. And then Stevie Wonder came in and Stevie was playing Mrs. Mills.
格拉迪斯·米尔斯，她过去常写一些英国酒吧歌曲和合唱曲。她的钢琴留下了，他们叫它“Mrs. Mills”。它还在那里，因为他们，他们拒绝把它卖给保罗。而且，我们在加州有我们自己的“Mrs. Mills”，同样的型号，施坦威。和我一起工作的那个家伙，安德鲁，他让埃尔顿·约翰在那里弹奏“Mrs. Mills”。保罗进来弹奏了“Mrs. Mills”，因为他们一起录了一首歌。我们做了几首歌，他把“Mrs. Mills”弹得太棒了。然后史蒂夫·旺达进来了，史蒂夫在弹“Mrs. Mills”。
And I started thinking about how this piano preferred not to be owned. She just wanted to be there with all the, all these fantastic men were laying their hands all over her. And she liked it that way. So that's what the song's about. And it did have kind of a beatlesque feel to it, a feel. And we thought, speaking of fills, we thought about, you'd kind of go for a Ringo-type sound on the drums. And then we were able to reach him and he was joyfully contributed and made it into something really, really special. So we got to sit and record and play with Ringo. And it was just a real education.
我开始思考这架钢琴更喜欢不被拥有。她只是想和所有这些，所有这些出色的男人把手放在她身上。她喜欢那样。所以这就是这首歌的内容。它确实有一种披头士的感觉，一种感觉。我们想，说到填充，我们想，你会想在鼓上追求一种林戈式的声音。然后我们联系到了他，他愉快地贡献了，并使它变得非常，非常特别。所以我们得以坐下来录音并和林戈一起演奏。那真是一次真正的教育。
Do you like it? Oh yeah. All three of those he sent were just, genuinely meant what I said. I could listen to these on a loop for a week straight to not get tired. How the hell do I get wasted on Bateman? Bateman doesn't appreciate anything. Eddie, I wanted to finish, we started the whole thing with me recounting the time that I worked at Illinois State University. Yes. At the concert with you.
你喜欢吗？哦，是的。他发来的那三首，我真心实意地说了我所说的。我可以循环听这些听一个星期都不觉得累。我怎么会在贝特曼身上浪费时间？贝特曼什么都不欣赏。埃迪，我想结束，我们开始整个事情时，我讲述了我在伊利诺伊州立大学工作的那次。是的。在和你一起的演唱会上。
Let's go back to that for sure. No, wait, because I wanted to finish. Because you grew up in Chicago? Yeah, I grew up in Glen Allen, Illinois, summer of Chicago. That's west of Chicago, that's... Correct. Yeah. You were in Evanston, I think.
让我们回到那个，肯定。不，等等，因为我想结束。因为你在芝加哥长大？是的，我在伊利诺伊州的格伦艾伦长大，芝加哥的夏天。那是芝加哥的西边，那是……正确。是的。我想你在埃文斯顿。
I was north, yeah. You were about the same distance. Anyway, I was at this concert. It was, again, it was you, it was Pearl Jam, Red Hot Chili Peppers, and Smashing Pumpkins. And so, and you, I was, I weighed, I weighed like 70 pounds, and they let us in the front row, and I worked with the security. So when you did the body surfing and jumped into the crowd, I am the one who had to keep everybody off the stage. So they wouldn't rush it, and I was like... Wait a second.
我在北边，是的。你们距离差不多。不管怎样，我在那场演唱会上。那是，再说一次，是你，是珍珠果酱乐队，红辣椒乐队，还有碎南瓜乐队。所以，还有你，我当时，我体重，我体重大概70磅，他们让我们进了前排，我和安保一起工作。所以当你做人体冲浪跳进人群时，我是那个必须把所有人挡在舞台外的人。这样他们就不会冲上来，我当时……等一下。
I was 19 years old at 70 pounds, thinking I could hold back a crowd rushing the stage to get to Eddie Vedder. And let's not forget, super, super gay. Oh, my God. Oh, yes, you pointed out super. I wore a cape, I was so gay. Oh, please. A cape is a security. Oh, God.
我19岁，70磅，以为我能挡住冲向舞台去见埃迪·维德的人群。别忘了，超级，超级同性恋。哦，天哪。哦，是的，你指出了超级。我穿了斗篷，我太同性恋了。哦，拜托。斗篷是安保。哦，上帝。
Oh, boy. So the question is, Sean, the question is... Did you feel safer knowing that Sean was there? Exactly. Did you feel safer? I do remember you by, you jumped into the crowd, didn't you? Didn't you used to do that? Yeah.
哦，天哪。所以问题是，肖恩，问题是……知道肖恩在那里，你觉得更安全吗？确切地。你觉得更安全吗？我确实记得你，你跳进了人群，不是吗？你过去常那样做吗？是的。
Yeah, that would be a nightly occurrence. And then the chili peppers would play, and then I'd do it a bunch more, just for fun. Are you still doing that when you guys are going out and playing those huge venues? When's the last time you jumped into the pit? Trying to think. Jill would not be happy. It was fun in the 20 movie or whatever, the Cameron Crow Pro-Damn documentary. There was maybe a four-minute thing of just all the montage of me jumping in and watching my young kids react.
是的，那会是每晚发生的事情。然后红辣椒乐队会演奏，然后我会再做几次，只是为了好玩。当你们出去在那些巨大的场地演奏时，你还在那样做吗？你上次跳进坑里是什么时候？我在想。吉尔不会高兴的。在20电影里或者别的什么，卡梅伦·克罗的珍珠果酱纪录片里很有趣。大概有四分钟的蒙太奇，全是我跳进去，看着我年幼的孩子们的反应。
That was pretty fun. Did anybody just grab your junk one time? Oh, Sean. Sean, this isn't like the bushes behind the pit. What do you think he's jumping in the pit, you dumbass? I'm just all about crutch grab. I mean, they had to have. Actually, maybe that explains the calluses, but yeah, so maybe...
那很有趣。有没有人有一次抓了你的下体？哦，肖恩。肖恩，这不像坑后面的灌木丛。你以为他在坑里跳什么，你这个笨蛋？我只是关于抓裆。我是说，他们肯定有。其实，也许那解释了老茧，但是的，所以也许……
Yes. Calluses. Are you close to rescheduling your dates that you owe us on the domestic tour? I think I said there were two there for the forum in Los Angeles. Are we close to resetting those? Yeah. Yeah, I think we're going back to Europe in the summer, and I think there's been some that's being announced in the States hopefully before that. I'm not sure if they've been announced, but that's the plan.
是的。老茧。你离重新安排你在国内巡演中欠我们的日期近了吗？我想我说过洛杉矶论坛球场有两个。我们离重置那些近了吗？是的。是的，我想我们夏天要回欧洲，我想在美国有一些希望在那之前宣布。我不确定它们是否已经宣布，但那是计划。
Okay. Don't make like you don't know us when those come out. Come on, guys. Yeah, man. I don't think you know how much I like you as well. Well, we're going to be all over you when you get out there. Oh, my God. Are we all over it?
好的。那些出来的时候别装作不认识我们。来吧，伙计们。是的，伙计。我不认为你知道我有多喜欢你。好吧，当你出去的时候，我们会围着你的。哦，天哪。我们围着它吗？
Let's speak about your... I'm going to body surf over. Are you going to... The band. Where the t-shirt says, please grab here in an arrow to your junk. What... Talk to me about scoring movies briefly or longly however you want. Your work with Sean Penn is fantastic.
让我们谈谈你的……我要人体冲浪过去。你会……乐队。T恤上写着，请抓这里，箭头指向你的下体。什么……简短或长篇地跟我谈谈电影配乐，随你喜欢。你和肖恩·潘的合作太棒了。
Is that something that you enjoy doing? I mean, you're mostly writing songs for those films as opposed to scoring to picture. Yes? Question? Yeah, I think Sean is really the driving force behind all that. I feel like the ones that have meant the most or anything at all were really just the Sean ones. And working with Sean is great, as you know, because he can be as much as he's my older brother. And we're so close, but he's still a terrifying individual.
那是你喜欢做的事情吗？我是说，你主要是为那些电影写歌，而不是为画面配乐。是吗？问题？是的，我想肖恩真的是这一切背后的驱动力。我觉得那些最有意义的，或者说有任何意义的，真的只是肖恩的那些。和肖恩一起工作很棒，如你所知，因为他可以，尽管他是我的大哥。我们如此亲密，但他仍然是一个可怕的人。
And it will really bring out the best in you. And even lyrically, if you've ever been out with Sean, he might at three in the morning kind of recite a Dylan song with nine verses and do it perfectly. And so when you write, you want to give him something that's worthy of reciting at some point. He's just been a great collaborator. And this last one we did, Flag Day, that came out just a few months ago, is just another great experience. And his daughter is just incredible in it. He's incredible in it. Your daughter participated as well, yeah?
他真的会激发你最好的一面。甚至在歌词上，如果你和肖恩出去过，他可能会在凌晨三点背诵一首有九段的迪伦的歌，而且做得完美无缺。所以当你写作时，你想给他一些值得在某个时刻背诵的东西。他一直是一个伟大的合作者。我们做的最后一个，Flag Day，几个月前刚出来，是又一次伟大的经历。他的女儿在里面简直不可思议。他不可思议。你的女儿也参与了，是吗？
Well, yeah, I love the story because she was just a stand-in vocalist. We were writing songs, Glenn Hansard and I, the great... I love that guy. Irish singer, person, Irish human, Irish earthling. But he... we came up with this song. We really wanted Sean to hear, but we didn't have our female vocalist for another week or so. And so I just asked my daughter to come down and give it a whirl. And she doesn't spend a lot of time saying, you know, she's shy about it and very humble and just kind of enjoys it. But she came in and I played it for Sean and it was something about her voice and the vulnerability of it and that it was just kind of perfect for the song.
嗯，是的，我喜欢这个故事，因为她只是一个替补歌手。我们在写歌，格伦·汉萨德和我，伟大的……我爱那个家伙。爱尔兰歌手，人，爱尔兰人类，爱尔兰地球人。但他……我们想出了这首歌。我们真的很想让肖恩听听，但我们还要一个星期左右才有我们的女歌手。所以我只是让我女儿下来试一试。她花的时间不多，你知道，她对此很害羞，非常谦虚，只是有点享受它。但她进来了，我给肖恩放了，她的声音和那种脆弱感，这对于这首歌来说简直太完美了。
So he said, not only do I like the song, but this version. And there was also great symmetry because it was him and his daughter and then Olivia as well. So it was a great experience and then the craziest, coolest thing which we could have never predicted and even a week before had no idea what happened or three days before. But Olivia came up and sang on stage when we played the Ohana Festival with all her uncles, you know, in the band, you know, from Glenn to Chad Smith to Josh and Andrew and all these great players. So it was kind of like she had the perfect wave and she surfed the shit out of it. She sang great and that was a big thing to be in front of people. Eddie, speak a little bit because you just talked about Glenn Hansard, who I'm such a fan of his music. I'm so happy that you guys, the idea of you guys working together for whatever reason makes me really, really happy.
所以他说，我不但喜欢这首歌，而且喜欢这个版本。而且还有很好的对称性，因为是他和他的女儿，还有奥利维亚。所以那是一次伟大的经历，然后是最疯狂，最酷的事情，我们永远无法预测，甚至一周前都不知道会发生什么，或者三天前。但奥利维亚上来在舞台上唱了，当我们演奏Ohana音乐节时，和她所有的叔叔们一起，你知道，在乐队里，你知道，从格伦到查德·史密斯到乔什和安德鲁，还有所有这些伟大的乐手。所以这就像她抓住了完美的浪，她冲浪冲得太棒了。她唱得很好，在人们面前表演是一件大事。埃迪，说一点，因为你刚才谈到了格伦·汉萨德，我是他音乐的粉丝。我很高兴你们，你们一起工作的想法，不管什么原因，让我真的，真的很高兴。
Tell me about your relationship with Glenn and how that came to be. Tell it quick, the crazy thing, or I mean, it came from such a tragedy in a way because he was playing somewhere in Oregon. And I read about it the next day that during the set, some young man who obviously had some deep, deep issues, walked away from his girlfriend, left her in the crowd. Next thing you know, he was jumping from the back of the stage onto the stage and killed himself. It happened behind Glenn. Glenn thought maybe an amp had fallen over. It got even more hectic because it was a one, two lane burrowed into the venue like a winery or something. He was there with his group's well season and all the crowd had to stay put so they could get emergency vehicles in and out. So everyone was kind of watching this thing happen.
告诉我你和格伦的关系，以及它是怎么来的。快点说，那件疯狂的事，或者我是说，它在某种程度上源于一场悲剧，因为他在俄勒冈州的某个地方演出。第二天我读到，在演出期间，某个显然有一些深层，深层问题的年轻人，离开了他的女朋友，把她留在人群中。接下来你知道，他从舞台后面跳到舞台上，自杀了。它发生在格伦身后。格伦以为也许是一个扩音器倒了。情况变得更加混乱，因为那是一个像酒庄之类的场地，只有一条或两条车道。他和他的团队Well Season在那里，所有观众都必须留在原地，以便紧急车辆进出。所以每个人都在看着这件事发生。
Anyways, I was able to get his number and reached out that next day just to see how he was because we had gone through some stuff with the Ross Gilda thing, the concert where we had our own extra large dose of tragedy. So that's how we met on the phone. And then I called the next day and checked back in on him and they decided to keep playing, which I think for them was a great idea. And that's how we, our friendship started. And now we're again just brothers and I just love the guy. That's so great. Every day I get to see Glenn is a good day. Let me ask you a final question.
不管怎样，我设法得到了他的号码，第二天联系了他，只是想看看他怎么样，因为我们经历过罗斯·吉尔达的事情，那场演唱会我们有我们自己超大剂量的悲剧。所以这就是我们在电话里认识的方式。然后第二天我打电话回去看他，他们决定继续演奏，我认为这对他们来说是个好主意。这就是我们，我们的友谊开始的方式。现在我们又是兄弟了，我只是爱那个家伙。那太棒了。我每天能见到格伦都是美好的一天。让我问你最后一个问题。
We will let you go. You've been very generous with your time. This is the dumbest question of the morning. Do you want me to ask it? You're going to pretend Sean texted me and asked me to ask you this question. Oh, that's nice. It's really nice. And it's a final Pearl Jam question.
我们会让你走。你一直很慷慨地贡献你的时间。这是早晨最愚蠢的问题。你想让我问吗？你要假装肖恩发短信给我，让我问你这个问题。哦，那很好。真的很好。这是最后一个珍珠果酱乐队的问题。
Does the title of the band mean what I think it means? Go ahead and go. No, no, don't put it in my mind. Tell us what you think it means first. Well, I'm going to wait until he gives a little color on it. There's a slight grin on his face, listener. Well, the thing is I don't really know what it means. So you could be right.
乐队的名字意味着我想的那样吗？继续说。不，不，别把它放进我的脑子里。先告诉我们你认为它意味着什么。好吧，我要等他给它一点色彩。听众们，他脸上有一丝微笑。好吧，问题是我真的不知道它意味着什么。所以你可能是对的。
I think you do. Okay, there it is. Can you explain the grin? It's just a ridiculous question. It's a ridiculous question. It is. Thank you. Eddie better.
我想你知道。好吧，就是这样。你能解释一下那个微笑吗？这只是一个荒谬的问题。这是一个荒谬的问题。确实是。谢谢。埃迪·维德。
What do you think Pearl Jam means? I think it means whatever it wants. You know, first of all, Eddie better just clowned you, dude. You just got clowned by Eddie better. I think it means, can I say what I think it means? Go ahead, Sean. I think it means when a couple who is deeply in love with each other. This is very nice way to start.
你认为珍珠果酱意味着什么？我认为它意味着它想意味着什么。你知道，首先，埃迪·维德刚刚戏弄了你，伙计。你刚刚被埃迪·维德戏弄了。我想它意味着，我能说我认为它意味着什么吗？继续，肖恩。我认为它意味着当一对深爱着对方的夫妇。这是一个很好的开始方式。
Have an intimate relationship. Okay. And they have a leave behind during an intimate encounter. There's an organ scream. There's an organ scream. And what you get is Pearl Jam. And then you write music to it. You're talking about a dick barf?
有亲密关系。好的。他们在亲密接触后留下了一些东西。有一个器官尖叫。有一个器官尖叫。你得到的是珍珠果酱。然后你为它写音乐。你在说精液吗？
Whoa, bro. I don't know what I mean. Which was the other option for the band name? Dick barf was the original name. Pearl Jam knew it. Fucking dick barf. It didn't clear. It was already taken.
哇，兄弟。我不知道我的意思。那是乐队名字的另一个选择。Dick Barf是最初的名字。珍珠果酱知道。该死的Dick Barf。它没通过。它已经被占用了。
Oh my God. Did you guys hear about the Guar show? You know, Guar. Speaking of great band names. Did you see that they were playing a theater and they had somebody crowd surfing. And by the time he got pushed up on the stage, he had lost his prosthetic leg.
哦，天哪。你们听说过Guar的演出吗？你知道，Guar。说到伟大的乐队名字。你看到他们在剧院演出，有人在人群中冲浪。当他被推上舞台时，他丢了他的假腿。
No. So everyone had to scramble. And then they stopped the show. See, this is the good thing. Any singer should be able to stop the show. Anybody running the show, any promoter, should have a kill switch and be able to stop the show. It's just something you need to do.
没有。所以每个人都得争抢。然后他们停止了演出。看，这是好事。任何歌手都应该能够停止演出。任何经营演出的人，任何发起人，都应该有一个紧急停止开关，能够停止演出。这只是你需要做的事情。
And I tell you, when the leg comes up from the back of the crowd, it gets passed up just the leg. It's just fantastic. Filled with Pearl Jam at that point. By the time it gets to the front. Do you think that Eddie and I could play brothers? Do you think that I've had that in a bunch? Yeah.
我告诉你，当腿从人群后面上来时，它被传上来，只是腿。这太棒了。那时充满了珍珠果酱。当它传到前面时。你认为埃迪和我能演兄弟吗？你认为我以前经常那样吗？是的。
I was thinking about that early on. That's a compliment to me, by the way. It is. Yeah. Are you guys resisting the urge to just sing Eddie's songs? Yeah. I've been trying not to go out for a solid hour now. I keep wanting to go like, I don't mind.
我早就在想那个了。顺便说一句，那是对我的赞美。是的。你们在抵制只是唱埃迪的歌的冲动吗？是的。我已经努力一个小时没唱了。我一直想去，我不介意。
Keep it together. No, don't do it. We're about to get away with it. Okay. Eddie. Eddie. But it's on the table. Sorry.
保持住。不，别做。我们快要逃脱了。好的。埃迪。埃迪。但它在桌面上。抱歉。
I just can't fucking. Man, I love you, Eddie, dude. I love you. You're a beast. And until we see you in Inglewood, please be well. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you for doing this.
我只是不能该死的。伙计，我爱你，埃迪，伙计。我爱你。你是个野兽。在我们英格尔伍德见到你之前，请保重。是的。谢谢。谢谢你做这个。
Such a pleasure and an honor to meet you. I got some. I really, really love you guys. Thank you. Man. Likewise. Thank you, Eddie. Be well.
见到你真是荣幸和荣幸。我有一些。我真的，真的爱你们。谢谢。伙计。同样。谢谢，埃迪。保重。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. And hopefully we see you soon. Much love, fellas. All right, Eddie. Bye, buddy. Bye.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。希望我们很快见到你。多爱，伙计们。好的，埃迪。再见，伙计。再见。
Bye. You guys are welcome. Okay. You're welcome. I just walked on. There's about half a dozen true rock stars in this world. I agree. There goes one of them.
再见。你们受欢迎。好的。不客气。我刚走进来。这个世界上大概有半打真正的摇滚明星。我同意。那走了一个。
Wait. How do you know him, Jay? What are you? I just, you know, he doesn't know me. He doesn't know me, Sean. He doesn't know him at all. But I requested and he was nice enough to say yes. That's so nice.
等等。你怎么认识他的，杰伊？你是谁？我只是，你知道，他不认识我。他不认识我，肖恩。他根本不认识他。但我请求了，他很友好地说好。那太好了。
I met Eddie. I met him at SNL like, like 15 years ago, maybe longer and longer. It was like, yeah, 15, 16 years ago. This was the photo that he remembers so clearly. Yeah. He took it. And it was like the first, it wasn't whenever it was before the iPhone and he had an actual camera.
我见过埃迪。我在SNL见过他，大概15年前，也许更久，更久。就像，是的，15，16年前。这就是他记得那么清楚的照片。是的。他拍的。那是第一次，不是无论什么时候，在iPhone之前，他有一个真正的相机。
And I was on 8H right after the show. We hung out after it too, but we were in the thing and I was just waiting at 8H to talk to somebody and Eddie comes over. He had a briefcase with them, which was funny. No joke. And then he goes, and they just performed on the show. And then he goes, hey, do you mind if we take a photo? And I was like, what?
我在演出后就在8H。我们在那之后也一起玩，但我们在那个东西里，我只是在8H等着和某人说话，埃迪过来了。他带着公文包，这很有趣。不开玩笑。然后他说，他们刚在节目上表演完。然后他说，嘿，你介意我们拍张照吗？我当时想，什么？
And then he produced, he's got a camera. He's just been taking photos. He asked you to take a photo with him. Yeah. Good Lord. And it was, I couldn't, and then I went and talked to him and the rest of the guys at the after party, like Mike McCready and those dudes, and Mike McCready was a big arrested fan.
然后他拿出了，他有一个相机。他一直在拍照。他让你和他拍张照。是的。天哪。而且是，我不能，然后我去和他在庆功宴上和剩下的伙计们说话，比如迈克·麦克里迪和那些家伙，迈克·麦克里迪是一个大的《Arrested Development》粉丝。
Oh yeah? Yeah. And we were still on the original, on air on the original Fox version. You know, the more guys that are like rockers, the more, because you know, growing up, you only see them in videos. You just hear their songs. You just assume they're like testosterone filled, tough guys are going to kick my ass. Then you meet them at like the heart of gold, gentle giants, like the sweetest.
哦，是吗？是的。我们还在原来的，在原来的福克斯版本上播出。你知道，越多的摇滚乐手，因为你知道，成长过程中，你只在视频里看到他们。你只听到他们的歌。你只是假设他们是那种充满睾酮的，强硬的家伙，会踢我的屁股。然后你在像金子般的心，温柔的巨人，像最甜美的人那样见到他们。
That's what I meant about Eddie's music, about his vulnerability to his music and the way that made it. It's so interesting. There was power and emotion that matched the weight of their musical sound too. And it's okay, Sean, to what you were saying, it's okay for men to be vulnerable in that way and express themselves in that way. That's what a real man is. I couldn't agree more.
这就是我说的关于埃迪的音乐，关于他音乐的脆弱性以及它制作的方式。太有趣了。有一种力量和情感与他们音乐声音的重量相匹配。肖恩，你说得对，男人以那种方式脆弱并以那种方式表达自己是可以的。那才是一个真正的男人。我完全同意。
And I don't know about you guys. I mean, he just said it. And I said it to him. And I say it to you guys all the time. You know, there was a, it felt like it wasn't okay for men to say, I love you to their friends. Right. And I say it all the time. It's really important.
我不知道你们。我是说，他刚才说了。我也对他说了。我一直对你们说。你知道，有一种，感觉男人对他们的朋友说“我爱你”是不可以的。对吧。我一直说。这真的很重要。
I love you. I love you too. And I think it's so true because it's like, oh, it's too scary to say that. No, it's not. It only makes you evolve. Sure. And I mean, and- Fuck you, Jason.
我爱你。我也爱你。我认为这是真的，因为就像，哦，说那个太可怕了。不，不是。它只会让你进化。当然。我是说，而且——去你的，杰森。
Well, I'm just saying in the past, you know, it used to be like, if you said, I love you to a man, people would think that you were gay or maybe even, bye. Bye. Old school. Bye. Smart. What? Smart.
好吧，我只是说在过去，你知道，它过去就像，如果你对一个男人说“我爱你”，人们会认为你是同性恋，或者甚至，再见。再见。老派。再见。聪明。什么？聪明。
What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart. What? What?
什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？什么？
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？
What? Hello, I'm Joe, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
什么？你好，我是乔、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·阿姆朱尔夫。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。